[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau v y paie sur tv 78 une
émission dans laquelle nous vous
présentons les acteurs du territoire
yvelinois aujourd'hui je suis accompagné
de uri si bon jour et mangera vous vous
êtes l'auteur des aventures de may
masque déjà vous pouvez nous nous
présenter ce projet qu'est ce que les
aventures de mama les aventures de mama
alors ce sont
des livres qui racontent d'expériences
de vie d'une petite fille âgée de 2 ans
et demi et qui rentrent en maternelle
donc mama c'est un personnage vous dites
issus de la diversité est ce que pouvait
un peu nous à décrire décrire sa
personnalité alors mme hama donc comme
je disais elle a deux ans et demi elle
est black et elle est tirée c'est en
fait c'est une histoire de tiré d'une
histoire vraie tout simplement parce
qu'il s'agit de ma nièce et
elle est là les jeux crepuq hommes comme
je le décris dans l'histoire elle est
hyper dynamique curieuse et vive pleine
d'esprit et c'est ce qu'on va retrouver
dans l'ensemble des livres de la
collection des aventures de mama est
justement que le premier livre de cette
collection c'était ma mamma au pot donc
on va peut-être le montrer à l'écran
voilà mama bâ au pot
justement il ya combien dit dans cette
collection alors dans ce livre pour le
moment il y en a 17 ans ensemble je n'ai
pas pris le temps de conté il me semble
qu il y en a 17 déjà 10 cm est ce que
pour nous donner un exemple donc
peut-être de mama bâ au pot ou un autre
nous décrire un peu ce qui se passe dans
l'histoire comme ans raconte par exemple
dans
dans mamma va au bout puisque c'est le
premier livre de la collection les
aventures de mama
dans mes mains
appréhendant fait d'aller aux toilettes
toute seule comme une grande donc du
coup le pape a décidé d'acheter un pot
dans lequel voilà elle peut
coller des vignettes de déco de
décorations pour l'initier et pour
justement qu'elle appréhende voilà que
ça atténue sa peur d'aller au pot et lui
donne envie d'y aller et avec et pied
d'être fiers d'en sortir fier d'avoir
fait cette oeuvre
est justement vous ces livres-là voulait
donner parfois justement avec des
vignettes pour que les enfants puissent
identifier et puissent se coller eux
mêmes leur vignette derrière alors en
effet c'est vrai que à la campagne à la
fin de la campagne de
du des livres de la collection des
aventures de mama pour pour sortir pour
que les enfants puissent tout de suite
s'investir dans le livre et puis dans
l'eure dans leur projet d'année aux
toilettes et pour aider les parents j'ai
sorti les vignettes afin que les parents
puissent voilà accompagner le livre des
vignettes pour rejoindre vraiment
l'ensemble de ce projet parce que ça
c'est un projet éducatif justement mais
on va revenir là dessus c'est un projet
éducatif vous dites donc en fait c'était
ça l'idée c'était de sortir des
histoires qui soient pour les enfants
mais qui soit aussi pédagogique ludique
oui alors pas que donc c'est pour ça que
l'on prête à la fin du livre donc je me
permets si ça vous dérange ou à à la fin
du livre le fait il ya un petit jeu donc
on joue avec avec mama dans lequel voilà
on voit les les couleurs et puis les
chiffres donc en fait le but c'est que
les enfants puissent découvrir les
couleurs à prendre des couleurs et puis
en même temps apprendre à découvrir les
chiffres et aussi à compter parce que
normalement dans toute la série des
livres il ça va jusqu'à 10 voilà le
maximum ses 10 donc ça c'est à la fin de
chaque livre on peut retrouver un jeu
pour les enfants c'est sa couleur et
chiffres et à côté de ça en fait le
livre permet en fait chaque vente de
livres permet de reverser un euro en
fait à une association pour lesquelles
en fait
la collection les aventures de mama
soutien justement ces associations a
donc vous êtes engagés et chaque livre
chaque livre qu'on achète on reverse
enfin vous reverser un euro à une
association voilà donc chaque
association en fait et les chaque livre
est plutôt est affiliée à une
association bien particulière donc par
exemple les à mamao peau est associée à
la pouponnière de bourdon qu'à chaque
fois qu'un livre est vendu de
mama mama au pot le livre m'avait
beaucoup à chaque fois qu'il sera vendu
1 euro sera reversé en fait à la
pouponnière de m'bour le livre mama et
le loup est associé en fait à
l'association les bag noz à manon qui
est située dans les yvelines et donc du
coup un euro est reversé en fait à
chaque fois à cette association dès que
ce livre là est vendu et pourquoi c'est
important pour vous justement de de
faire ça de reverser 1 aura une
association d'être engagé finalement
pour ces causes alors tout simplement
parce que j'ai toujours été une personne
engagée j'ai toujours voilà donné de ma
personne pour les associations notamment
pour les enfants j'ai commencé déjà très
jeune dès que j'avais des petits sous je
donnais aux associations pour enfants
donc du coup pour moi c'était tout à
fait normal je voulais pas que ce soit
des livres voilà voilà dans lequel je
reçois tous les bénéfices donc pour moi
c'était logique qu'ils aient au moins 1
euro reversé à une association
donc ces histoires dont on vient de
parler justement mama les aventures de
mama ça s'adresse à à quel âge pour les
enfants alors moi je dirais que le plus
tôt possible c'est mieux voilà de
commencer à dire en face on n'y a pas
d'âge pour commencer à lire de toute
façon les parents dès qu'un enfant né
pour commencer ce que j'ai fait j'ai
acheté des livres j'ai commencé à
raconter des histoires et puis même
avant la naissance on peut aussi
raconter des histoires à son enfant qui
est dans le ventre
après c'est généralement je dirais
jusqu'à 5-6 ans parce que c'est
les enfants qui ont acheté mon livre
avait pour les derniers plus âgé avait
entre cinq six ans donc pour ceux qui
sont en fait dans l'apprentissage de la
lecture c'est ça peut être aussi pas mal
parce que les chiffres les lettres sont
assez sont assez grosse et en plus elles
sont adaptées aux enfants dyslexiques
on va revenir sur le personnage de
mamadou bah vous ne vous l'avais dit
tout à l'heure en fait c'est inspiré de
votre nièce est-ce que c'est elle aussi
qui vous a inspiré en fait de par son
expérience pour faire ces histoires tout
à fait parce que bah c'était une requête
de ma petite soeur à la base
elle m'a pas demandé de faire les livres
mais elle m'a demandé de trouver une
solution pour l'aider à aller au pot
puis moi je suis j'aime bien voilà
raconter des histoires aux enfants je
suis traîné dans le monde de
l'imagination donc du coup vers minuit
je commence à écrire un petit un petit
texte puis après ça ressemble à une
histoire donc du coup j'ai un petit peu
étoffés et bien à la fin ça va
ressembler un livre et du coup je dis ah
bah tiens ça me fait penser que je
pourrais je peux faire des livres donc
je me suis lancé comme ça dans cette
aventure et justement cette aventure
elle est assez récent finalement est-ce
qu'elle date de l'année dernière le
confinement en plein confinement
effectivement et donc du coup j'ai fait
une campagne participative pour m'aider
dans ce projet notamment pour financer
tout ce qui est l'illustration et
impression de l'impression de livres
donc
de ça il ya eu un fort succès dans ce
bas des marches donc c'était trois mois
trois mois de campagne assez assez
intense je les fais par le biais de
de la plateforme ulule et ça a très bien
fonctionné et je pense que le
confinement aussi m'a beaucoup aidé dans
cette mise en avant et c'est ce
confinement qui vous a donné envie de
vous lancer finalement pas ce que vous
vouliez à écrire depuis très longtemps
et qu'est-ce qui a fait que ça a
déclenché cette idée là bas tout d'abord
l'appel de ma soeur et puis en plus je
me suis mise à écrire je me suis entre
guillemets remise à dessiner puisque je
dessine un petit peu mais moi j'ai plus
une mémoire photographique je serai pas
dessiner les personnages en mouvement et
répéter on va dire des saynètes donc
c'est pas trop mon mon corps de métier
donc je préfère le laisser à un
illustrateur c'est parti comme ça par
l'appel de ma soeur et puis de me dire
que je pouvais écrire c et puis cette
envie et puis le temps qu'ils mettaient
aussi consacré que faire pendant le
confinement comment s'occuper comme un
pc ou le temps et ben voilà c'est le
résultat final est justement vous diriez
que le confinement vous avez des
finalement parce que est ce que les gens
sont bien plus à lire ou alors c'est il
ya eu des études ont justement qui ont
parlé de qui ont évoqué que le
confinement à ce site et plus d'envié de
devenir donc
peut-être que c'est dû à ça que mes
ventes aussi ont décollé et puis en plus
mama est issu de la diversité il ya très
peu de livres de d'enfants blacks dans
les bibliothèques même dans les écoles
ont proposé dans les écoles donc bah
c'est aussi l'occasion de sortir on va
dire des sentiers battus puis de
proposer autre chose à toute la
population qu'elle soit
saint-quentinoise ou nationales et donc
la halle et livrent donc c'est vous qui
faites les histoires de ces livres là
par exemple j'ai mama et le loup par
contre les illustrations donc vous êtes
associé avec quelqu'un pour les
illustrations tout à fait donc il s'agit
de donadille et qu'on appelle aussi une
année
donc c'est une illustratrice voilà que
que avec qui je collabore pour
l'illustration de l'ensemble des livres
de la collection des aventures de mama
et vous êtes aussi vraiment ancrée sur
les réseaux sociaux la même une team
mama qui sait oui mon street qu'est ce
que c'est que ce groupe est ce que vous
pouvez nous en parler un petit polar de
la team mama se sont tous les enfants
qui ont apprécié et adoré les livres de
la collection les aventures de mama ce
sont les premiers qui ont acheté des
livres le livre qui est le premier
ouvrage qui est sorti donc mamao peau et
qui ont acheté en plus le suivant qui
est sorti donc mama et le loup
qui m'ont fait tous un retour
extrêmement positif
envoyer des vidéos c'est les parents qui
m'ont envoyé des textos pour me dire que
c'est génial ils ont adoré donc voilà
c'est la petite maddie mama qui m'ont
envoyé des vidéos et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que
que j'ai fait un espèce de faux une
espèce de photos de classe donc qu'on
voit un petit peu là sur mon petit
dossier de presse donc bah on va tous
les enfants est entré sans voix sur mon
facebook est également sur mon instagram
et - youtube les enfants qui s'expriment
et qui me racontent qui me lisent
l'histoire donc ça fait vraiment plaisir
et justement c'est important pour vous
d'avoir ce retour finalement de vos
lecteurs du public ben oui parce que
tout simplement parce que ça veut dire
que le livre il est bien fait c'est
aussi le
le but c'est que ça soit bien fait que
ça soit lui et que ça donne envie de
devenir et d'acheter tout simplement et
de continuer sur toute la collection des
aventures de mama et c'est la première
chose est de
parts
le fait que les enfants ne me fasse ce
retour du coup je me dis que c'est
vraiment adapté et que le langage est
vraiment adapté aux enfants et donc
après ça se construit un peu une
communauté c'est super dur parce qu'en
fait ils vous envoient un peu les
avancées de leur vie comment eux ils ont
réussi peut-être grâce au livre assez
apprentissage de la vie en fait tout
simplement bah oui parce que ils
s'associent le retour des parents comme
les enfants à moi si je suis allé à la
piscine parce que bientôt il y aura ma
naadam dans la piscine moi si j'ai
réussi à aller au pot on voit là on me
dit toutes les réussites et je me dis ça
fonctionnait sur ma nièce en plus et ça
fonctionne surtout d'autres enfants donc
voilà il ya tout le côté pédagogique et
éducatif qu'on retrouve dans cet été
aussi mon but et c'est vraiment c'est
gratifiant de savoir que
bac 5 uc que tout fonctionne en fait est
là pour l'instant vous avez combien de
livres vendus à peu près de 200
approximativement 200 ça fait à peu près
dudit livre par
par mois devant du même si des fois j'ai
plus un mois qui est assez intense donc
quand c'est à proximité dans saint
quentin en yvelines je peux les déposer
en mains propres et c'est encore mieux
donc comme c'est un petit peu plus
éloignés bonjour envoi par la poste
quelle est la suite pour vous finalement
est ce que on va continuer dans cette
série là est ce qu'on va finalement
commencé une nouvelle collection où est
ce qu'on va chercher peut-être un
éditeur parce que vous êtes en auto
édition
quelle est la suite qu'est ce qu'on peut
vous souhaiter alors ce qu'on peut me
souhaiter c'est de trouver une maison
d'édition principalement parce que bon
bah c'est vrai que c'est tout un travail
le côté promotionnel le côté écriture
ces deux paramètres qui sont
complètement différents et encore il
n'ya pas que le côté écriture parce
qu'il faut aussi de rêver toute la
partie construction technique parce que
en fait il ya des illustrations dadié et
puis on a aussi le graphiste qui est
gauthier 1 million whisky qui est qui
mais c'est qu'il fait la mise en page du
livre d d'ensemble des livres de la
collection des aventures de mama donc
oui une maison d'édition ce serait
vraiment la bienvenue
merci beaucoup ici en tout cas on vous
le souhaite merci d'avoir été avec nous
et puis je le rappelle vous êtes donc
l'auteur des aventures de mama merci
beaucoup et on peut retrouver vos livres
dans plusieurs librairies montigny le
bretonneux le pavé du canal c'est ça et
également chez jouéclub et
également dans des boxes littéraire il
ya une île box et maya box est versée
noté chez vous c'est la fin de ce v y
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi et à
très bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]